what was your issue with the first one
before we get into the second one look I
didn't hate it hate I don't want like
the Fanboys coming after me it's okay
it's okay we don't like the same movies
but I was I definitely remember watching
the screening and everybody around me
laughing the entire time and I felt like
MTV's Daria where she just sits during
the theater just looking at everybody
feeling like an alien so I felt like
actually from space and so man that's a
good point I left twice in the first
movie and I actually felt that Star-Lord
uh even though Chris Pratt you know good
actor uh he was trying to be Kurt
Russell from the 80s right he was trying
to be like Big Trouble in Little China
Kurt Russell how correct you were yes uh
and actually I think he actually ended
up suggesting to James Gunn to hire Kurt
Russell for ego's character
um so um I I don't know I felt old and I
was not into it and the second one I was
so pleasantly surprised because it was a
character story like it's actually
um you know like Fast and the Furious
it's about family right it's um it might
be the most Vin Diesel movie about
family exactly
heroes in the family exactly also one
big thing as we know that MCU has always
had a really bad villain problem for so
long until we met Thanos it's actually
until we met ego right ego was the first
MCU villain that I was like this is a
real villain that is actually complex
like ego is basically the worst part of
all the humans and the guardian's
character like obviously car Russell
played him so well but not only is he
he's supposed to be charismatic and
Charming but he's a total psychopath
he's a narcissist that's trying to not
take over the world like Thanos like
he's actually uh trying to make the
universe or create a universe to be like
him right yeah which is the most totally
exactly it's the most egotistical
narcissistic thing right and and uh and
I mean the fact that he only cares to
have his son around to become more
powerful right talk about daddy issues
oh
[Music]
[Applause]